I remember when I was fighting I was
training at black house and uh
definitely someone I was like man I just
got the call from my manager and Ed
knows the game forever and I was like
man I don't like this match-up boy he
goes what are you talking about I don't
like the matchup and I feel like this
guy there's better matchups I know he
goes I tell my guys all the same thing
when you get to the UFC unless you can
find a way to beat anybody they offer
you you're not ready for the UFC he's
like you take that fight man you there's
so I can look at that guy and find ways
for you to beat him he's like but I tell
my guys do not fight in UFC unless
you're ready to face all of them he's
like it's not a feeder lead they're not
going to give any buildups they're doing
a little better now like they've learned
their lesson with like Darren till or
certain guys you see what they've done
with sugar Shawn O'Malley and Patty
pamlett where it might be a little you
know they're building sugar up they're
building Patty up but used to be you
know how I mean you're first fight lead
your first [__] fight insane